chris and i think we hit the looming
expansion of the nfl playoffs from 12 to
14 teams in every way we possibly could
with the exception of one angle that i
neglected to mention and didn't
organically come up but it's been hiding
in plain sight now that we know that
this is something that is going to be
part of the new cba and it's the reality
that the players don't seem to have a
problem with it no they don't we've
heard plenty of times hey 17 games oh we
don't want 17 games i haven't heard boo
about we don't want
14 playoff teams instead of 12. and
you'd think that that something would
have come up if the players had an issue
with it so i can only surmise that
they're fine with this yeah no it does
seem that way you know and again you
know i would like to keep things the way
they are i can deal with this seventh
you know team in each conference i don't
love it but i can deal with it you know
the formula okay
um now i think the players can get
behind this because you know it is the
playoffs i think that's the big thing it
gives you know two teams an extra chance
an extra crack at the super bowl and
proving your legacy
and yes it's a little different than the
17th game of the season where of course
everybody has to play that i think you
know the players can digest this a
little bit more because it's an extra
playoff check it's probably more money
in the pot all together all around and
it's a chance to
improve your legacy as a player because
then you get into the playoffs and
that's what people remember for you
those moments so uh i think that's
probably more than likely the reason the
players can get behind it but you're
right we've heard nothing no pushback
nothing about this really until
yesterday
and one of the realities is of having
only two teams get a buy the number one
seed in each conference you're gonna
have
12 teams that potentially will play
21 total games not not all 12 but if the
super bowl participant is anyone but the
one seed that team will have played 21
games chris that's where we're yeah yeah
sorry and soon to be 22 right yes
and and here's the here's the reality if
the next step
is what we believe 17 goes to 18 and 14
goes to 16
you will have every year
two teams
play
22
total games it is amazing when you think
about the standard college schedule used
to be 11 right now i know it's more than
that now but it used to be 11.
now you're looking at 22 total games two
teams not no obviously not all of them
but every year there'll be two teams
that play 22. it's asking a lot it is it
i i was gonna say this during the you
know during the show today but we just
we had so many different angles and
things to talk about i never got to it
but yeah that's a dramatic jump that's a
lot of football to be playing and again
this is going to take years of people's
careers away it's going to do that you
know because it's just more opportunity
to get hurt too and bang up your body
and do all that and you know to your
point with college football and
everything you know
they were talking a lot of the last few
years about you know these teams have
played 15 games never in history of
college football they played 15.
now you're gonna up that ante you know
by 50
i mean that that to me is just that
that's crazy basically it really is 22
games wow and and the most physical
brutal sport there is right now that is
rough and uh yeah that's a little scary
and again it just goes back to a little
bit of like yeah we talk about player
safety
but yeah and it's getting safer we're
making things go in the right direction
but you know these kind of conversations
just it's always seems to go back about
hey you know is it okay we're trying to
make it safer but we just want more
money that's all there is to it and
that's where it seems like it's going
more money and more things for people to
gamble on which will generate more money
as well they've wanted to expand the
regular season for years now and i think
the advent of legalized gambling state
by state and and really look it's going
to be 2021 2022 or 2023 when the regular
season expands the playoff expansion
would begin right away but as more and
more states go online with legalized
gambling that's when we see just the the
opportunity for the nfl to you know
roger goodell wants to get to 25 billion
this is a way to get to 25 billion this
is a way to get the 50 billion in time
especially when you throw international
growth of the league on top of it and
and look here's the reality
i feel like a deal is going to get done
soon
and if a deal doesn't get done
by the time the nfl sits down with the
networks to negotiate new tv contracts
and i don't know whether or not the nfl
will do it without a new cba in place i
know the nfl wants to do it chris with
labor piece but let's assume they don't
get a deal done
now and that it all gets tabled until
next year when the cba expires and we
get into 2021. there are three general
options that we need to be thinking of
because there's one specific strategy
that i believe the nfl players
association is bracing for now option
one is what happened in 2011. players
get locked out right negotiations
continue players are locked out and then
when the season rolls around and they're
looking at missing game checks they say
uncle and they get a deal done and they
come back the other option is for the
players to go on strike at some point
and we know from 1987 something your dad
lived through the strike doesn't work
because the players eventually are gonna
cave they're going to cry uncle they're
going to come back the other option is
this
negotiate to the point of impasse
contract expires the league can then
implement the last best offer that they
made to the players before the impasse
was reached you implement the rules and
the players have two choices deal with
those rules that have been unilaterally
implemented or go on strike well they're
not going to go on strike and the
concern is that the rules that get
implemented come 20 21
very well may be
18 regular season games right and a
lower percentage than what car you know
whatever the off the best offer is at
the time the impasse happens is what
gets implemented and the best offer
in august of 2021 may not be as good as
the best offer now precisely because of
the impact on the nfl of not doing the
new tv deals now when they can strike
while the iron's hot the iron may not be
as hot if they do the tv deals next year
so keep that in mind i think the union
is bracing for this possibility of a
lesser offer than what's currently on
the table being forced down their
throats next year yeah and they're going
to be dared to strike and they're not
going to strike that's interesting i did
you know you know again this is where
you're the man you're unbelievable with
these kind of things and i i can't even
digest everything you just said right
there uh but yes that would scare me as
a player you're right and of course as
you've mentioned and we've talked about
before yeah of course the players are in
a you know less than advantageous area
here first off they're football players
and the other side of the table and more
times than not are great businessmen and
the other side of the table have lots of
liquid cash to fall on if there is a
strike so they never panic the other
side of the table
only a few guys on every team have
enough liquid cash to kind of continue
to survive that way the middle class the
lower class of the nfl yeah a year off
from missing pay when you're a young guy
and you're just starting to accumulate
some money and wealth in your life
that's a huge blow to you and you only
have so many years to play football and
that's where players are truly at a
disadvantage here
especially compared to the other sports
too especially with no guaranteed
contracts or anything like that and
you're right the players are always
going to are going to fold uh at some
point or another and let me tell you
something
and this just kind of occurred to me as
you said what you said and this is why
it's good to have a chance to talk this
stuff through without having to worry
about going to break or anything else
the entire
professional sports model specifically
as it relates to football
just doesn't fit with the standard
labor management relationship situation
because
a strike in a normal business puts a ton
of pressure on that business because
it's not producing at that point they've
gotten higher scabs it's a lot harder to
hire scabs when you're a you know like a
a steel making operation or you know a
more typical company that would have a
strike
and you know you've got all these owners
number one they've got their money
number two plenty of them are making
money off of other business interests
anyway they can easily shut the nfl down
for a year and never feel the pain but
for the players you've got
big money that's gone right like if it's
a lower paying job i think in a weird
sort of way
you know it's easier to pay your bills
because you're living a more restricted
lifestyle anyway right if you're living
a lavish lifestyle all of a sudden
you've got no money what the hell do you
do right so i i really think this chris
and i don't want to get too far down the
rabbit hole on this i think the better
model for the nfl players association
long term
is to disband
and to treat the nfl
like 32 businesses
to hold the nfl accountable under the
anti-trust rules because the only reason
the nfl is allowed to have 32 businesses
come together and set all these rules
draft free agency
minimum salaries all of that is because
they are collectively negotiating with
players
if you get rid of that
and you force these 32 teams to truly
compete as 32 businesses
and anything they do collectively
becomes an anti-trust violation you know
i don't know how it plays out but i have
a feeling it may play out better for the
players under that scenario where they
have the hammer of antitrust litigation
any time those 32 businesses try to come
together and make collective rules and i
think at some point as this game as this
gets bigger and bigger at some point the
players need to have that philosophical
conversation as to whether or not they
are better off not being unionized but
being in an association that that
monitors uh potential anti-trust
activity files lawsuits whenever it
happens and treats 32 separate teams
like the 32 separate businesses they are
that's interesting i mean that's an
interesting take i mean i i don't know
what like you know i'd have to think
about that more i got to think about
what the negatives would be for the
players if they do that but you're right
it certainly seems like it would uh
make make it harder on owners in these
type of situations because now the onus
is on them more instead of just the nfl
and the shield all together helping each
other out that way so uh yeah that'd be
interesting mike i don't know if their
players are quite there yet but that
would be an interesting angle if that
came up here in the next few years
and here's what the biggest negative
would be if it was 32 independent
businesses that uh were all on
you know their own equal footing to do
whatever they wanted to do look at what
the xfl is doing look at how little
they're paying some of these guys
because the supply of football players
who can at least pass the eyeball test
right they may not be the greatest
players in the world but you put a
chicago bears uniform on a guy who
played at the college level oh we're
gonna watch it it's chicago bears he
plays for the bears but maybe he's gonna
be making peanuts in comparison to what
he's making under the protection of a
union i just i just i i just feel like
there are limitations because ultimately
the players aren't going to use that
hammer that most unionized workforces
and it's still it's still a difficult
thing for any unionized workforce to go
on strike i just feel like the dynamics
and the realities for professional
football make it harder you got a
limited career yes you've got big
salaries right it's a lot to sacrifice
your football games you want to play and
you want to get paid and when push comes
to shove the players are typically going
to cave in and do what the owners want
them to do
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports